I'm a big ham really I just get on that
stage and do it I don't really take
myself that seriously
not anymore there was a time where in
the early days where our music was very
pompous and very serious and people
thought oh what a lot of bores you know
and at that time we were getting a bit
serious everybody is serious to point
but after 10 years you know you've gotta
kind of ease off a little and I
personally just have a good time just
fooling around on stage you know and
that's why I'm not afraid to fall flat
on my face because I mean you know
coming up with some of the things that
we're sort of over the top I mean they
they have an element of humor which I
hope comes across that's basically what
it is now and if I'm seen to be having
fun on stage I think it kind of comes
across it's just good you can get very
blase with the public you know sometimes
you know you used to built up your
public and they only want you for a
certain thing that's the wrong way to go
about it but I'm concerned I mean they
should be aware of what you want to do
you can fall into a trap where you you
know you build up a sound or whatever
and then in the end that's all they want
and you're then manipulated by a public
that's the last thing I want to do it's
a nice it's a nice age that I'd like to
tread on which is which is good the
danger element is exactly what we need
and right now you know in a way telling
them that this is what we're doing right
now even though we do all the other
stuff that they like it's great for me
because it makes me work harder and you
just feel makes you keep on your toes
otherwise it would be just too easy I
couldn't get any more self-conscious
think oh that's the way I want to
perform you know it's taking grasping on
a song and delivering it the way I feel
you know I don't mean I mean I I don't
like sitting on a stool and doing the
whole performance same time I don't
wanna sort of run around all the time I
like to pace myself depending on what
the song content is I mean there are
ballads there
bawdy songs there are sort of them
there's certain songs that demand a lot
of energy
apart from just singing energy a lot of
visuals and I think you know I need to
do that
not really a lot of people ask me that
fun if I wanted I could have done that a
long time ago I feel that at the moment
there's a lot of things that I'm doing
within Queen that keeps me happy and as
far as being an actor or whatever is in
if I want to do anything I'm nah I'll do
it properly and I mean I need to really
feel ya interested in it
and a lot of people do it because I
think all right now they've done two or
three years in rock-and-roll to become
successful let's be movie stars
that's not mic that's not my bag at the
moment I'm quite happy doing what I want
to do it's very creative at the moment I
mean what we're doing within Queen is is
my creative output is within that is
enough for me
[Music]
[Applause]